[Musique]
une belle initiative pour nos amis les
chats à chanteloup-les-vignes une petite
cabane est maintenant mise à disposition
des chats du quartier à l'intérieur de
la chaleur et de la nourriture en libre
service côté sport le footballeur
yvelinois aurélien collin a décidé de
prendre sa retraite à 36 ans il avait
notamment remporté le championnat
américain de la major league soccer une
partie de la route nationale 12 a été
fermée dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
en cause un exercice de sécurité civile
dans le tunnel de chennevières au niveau
de jouars-pontchartrain un feu de forêt
s'est déclaré dans la commune de
rochefort en yvelines 70 pompiers et une
trentaine de camions ont été mobilisés
sur place plus de 8 hectares ont été
brûlés mais aucune habitation n'a été
impactée un contrat historique pour
ariane space filiale d'ariane groupe
basé aux mureaux dans le cadre du projet
keeper d'amazon 18 lancements de la
fusée ariane 6 vont être effectués et
puis côté loisirs un nouvel espace koh
lanta a été inaugurée pour la
réouverture annuelle du parc france
miniature avec la présence de clémence
castel double gagnante de l'émission
petits et grands pourront s'affronter
durant une série d'épreuves
[Musique]